And OUTFRONT this
evening, the breaking news.
Paul Pelosi,
the husband of House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi, is now out of surgery
for a fractured skull.
This after police say
an intruder broke
into their home overnight
and attacked with a hammer.
That intruder also attempted to tie Mr.
Pelosi up, quote, until Nancy got home.
This is according to sources.
Now, Speaker
Pelosi was in Washington at this time.
But sources tell CNN
the intruder repeatedly asked,
where is Nancy, where is Nancy?
And the rampage
now versus fact is now
identified as 42 year old David
de Pap of California.
He is facing charges
of attempted homicide,
as well as burglary, assault
with a deadly weapon, an elder abuse
I'm going to talk
to the district attorney
in charge of the case in just a moment.
Relatives are telling CNN
to permit a Facebook
page full of conspiracy theories.
These theories were about the 20, 20
election
and January six, specifically,
that image there was on one of them
and two blogs
written by a user
with the same name of the suspect
that we found have
anti-Semitic screens and QAnon
linked content,
including videos
with pictures of Speaker Pelosi in them.
And now this extremely
disturbing attack coming
just 11 days before Election Day.
Leaders from both parties
expressing outrage
in a rare show of unity.
Vice President
Harris says she's appalled by the attack.
And the Senate
minority leader Mitch
McConnell tweeted
he was horrified and disgusted.
Now, lawmakers
from both parties are also warning
that this is now anonymous sign a signal
about what still lies ahead.
It reminds me of January six
because when the insurrection
has broken the Capitol,
one of the first places
they went was to the speaker's office.
It just shows us the danger
that our democracy is sent.
This is what happens
when you convince a third of the country
that the election was stolen
and that the other side is an enemy.
This is not how democracies work.
This isn't how self-governance works.
This is
this is this is we're in a bad moment.
OUTFRONT now, Josh Campbell,
he is outside the Pelosi home
in San Francisco.
Josh, what else are investigators
learning about this attack?
And the suspect here
Well, Aaron, this individual
appears to be the exact type of person
that is law enforcement's
worst nightmare.
It's what they've been warning
about people
who not only consume
so many of these
conspiracy theories,
but also appears
to be predisposed to violence.
As you mentioned, this individual
social media presence
contained numerous conspiracy theories
about the election
about January 6th about COVID vaccines.
He retweeted reposted information
from Mike Lindell, the election
denying pillow salesman.
And again, he's
accused of coming here
to the home of Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
in the early morning hours today.
Turning this, residents behind me
into a crime scene
82 year old
Paul Pelosi, the
husband of House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi, undergoing
surgery today
after being violently attacked
with a hammer early Friday
morning at the Pelosi San Francisco home.
Speaker Pelosi was in Washington
at the time
special called Special Committee.
66 locations.
Police say they found Paul Pelosi
fending off an attacker
after responding to a request
for a priority
well-being check at the Pelosi home.
They encountered an adult male.
And Mr.
Pelosi's husband, Paul.
Our officers observed Mr.
Pelosi and the suspect
both holding a hammer.
The suspect pulled a hammer away from MS.
Pelosi
and violently assaulted him with it.
The assailant was searching
for the speaker,
according to a source
briefed on the attack.
He confronted Mr.
Pelosi, shouting, Where is Nancy?
Where is Nancy?
Our officers immediately
tackled the suspect, disarmed him,
took him into custody,
requested emergency backup,
and rendered medical aid.
Two sources
familiar with the investigation
tell CNN the attacker hit
Pelosi and attempted to tie him up
after breaking into the back of the home
around 2:30 a.m..
A suspect.
42 year old David de
Pap is now in custody.
His Facebook page, now taken down,
had post of means and conspiracy theories
about the 2020 election
and the January six attack at the U.S.
Capitol.
Not long ago,
Nancy Pelosi was a target of the January
six rioters with him hunting for
and trashing her office.
The motive for Friday's attack on her
husband is not yet known.
Mr.
De Pepe
will be booked
at the San Francisco
County Jail on the following charges.
Attempted homicide,
assault with a deadly weapon,
elder abuse,
burglary, and several
several other additional felonies.
The Speaker's office issued a statement
saying Mr.
Pelosi is expected
to make a full recovery
Now, Aaron, the residence
behind me
here was flooded with law enforcement
throughout much of the day.
Police, as well as FBI agents,
they appear
to be near
completing their processing of evidence
for the day.
Of course, this comes as we're learning
new information
about why
these officers
were brought to this location
to begin with.
CNN's John Miller
and Jamie Geller reporting
that Paul Pelosi was able to call 911
at the start of this attack
and was speaking in code as he engaged
with this attacker.
It was an adept dispatcher
who realized that something was wrong.
They sent police here to this location.
They were able to
ultimately tackle the suspect
and he remains in custody.
Authorities say they expect him to face
multiple charges,
including attempted homicide
and assault Aaron.
All right, Josh, thank you very much.
And as Josh was speaking,
we do have a development.
Our Dana Bash is reporting
that the speaker, Nancy
Pelosi, is now in San Francisco
and she is at the hospital
with her husband, Paul,
right now as I speak.
So she has obviously gotten
from Washington back to San Francisco
and she's there at the hospital.
I want to go now to the San
Francisco district attorney,
Brooke Jenkins
and District Attorney Jenkins.
I appreciate your time.
We understand
the suspect is facing of quite
a few charges.
Attempted murder is is the most serious.
What more are
you able to tell us about this incident
and what to plan to do?
Yes, and thank you.
And first,
I just want to extend our support
and our prayers
to Speaker Pelosi and her family.
And we truly hope for a speedy recovery
for Mr. Pelosi.
But what I can tell you is much of what
you have already reported,
which is that
this individual
forced his way into the Pelosi home
before eventually attacking Mr.
Pelosi with a hammer
before officers could intervene
and so he is facing
attempted murder charges.
Once we've reviewed this case,
but that that appears to be
which direction we're headed,
as well as assault with a deadly weapon
in residential burglary.
So we've also discovered
two blogs, district attorney
with the same name of the suspect
on these blogs.
Q And on Linked Content, a video
that showed Pelosi
during one of former
President Trump's impeachment.
Do you know anything about the suspect's
motive or how long he planned this?
I mean,
do you have any of this information
in hand yet?
No.
That is
a part of the ongoing investigation right
now, both
between the San
Francisco Police Department and the FBI.
So sources tell CNN the suspect
you talk about, he broke in
and then attacked,
you know, eventually attacked Mr. Pelosi.
We understand he was
he was saying, where is Nancy?
Where is Nancy?
And that he then tried to tie
Paul Pelosi
up, in his words, until Nancy got home.
You mentioned that
it seems likely the direction
this is going is these murder charges
Is there any question in your mind
right now
that he was intending
to kill Nancy Pelosi?
Right now, as I said, you know,
we don't know all of the facts just yet.
We are still in the
in the middle
of a proceeding investigation.
And so some of those details
of what was going on in the home prior
to the police arriving
are still things
that we're trying to flesh out.
But we do know that at the point
at which the police arrived, he did turn
and use that hammer
against the speaker's husband
in a manner that appeared
that he was intending to kill him.
And it is obviously very
significant that they
they saw that
and that that certainly indicated
intent to murder.
You know, we've learned that
part of the reason that this even
possibly didn't end
in such a horrific way
was that Paul Pelosi called 911
at the beginning of the attack
and was able to leave the phone line open
even as he and the attacker
continue to interact.
One source says the suspect's struggle
with Pelosi was been captured
on police body camera
as they came to the door
to intervene,
that this attack that you're referring to
is actually on camera.
What are more
you able to tell me, district attorney,
if anything, about that 911
call or the body cam video
Well, I can tell you right now is that
it is really thanks to Mr.
Pelosi having the ability
to be able
to make that call and truly the attention
and the instincts of that dispatcher
to realize that something was wrong
in that situation
and to make the police call a priority
so that they got there
within 2 minutes to
respond to this situation.
And so
we do have
to give her great credit
for her responsiveness for the police
at this
Have police
been able to speak to the suspect yet?
They have been able to speak with him.
But again,
like I said, given
the investigation is still ongoing.
None of that information
is being released at this hour.
You can't share that
are you able to tell us
anything about what condition
the suspect is in?
He did sustain some minor injuries,
but but that's all I can say.
Minor injuries.
All right.
Well, District Attorney,
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you very much for sharing what you
were able to share. Thanks.